black mirror
bander snatch has just hit netflix and
the tv's unique premise leaves a lot to
unpack from it
the show presents a pick your own
adventure style of storytelling that
allows the viewers to affect the outcome
of the show
due to the choices that they make whilst
watching it reportedly there's over 312
minutes of footage that is condensed
into roughly 90
depending on the plot branches that
watches take throughout this video i'll
be breaking down the choices that i made
and explaining what i took from the
ending there will of course be heavy
spoilers
so if you don't want to know anything
about bandersnatch then i highly suggest
that you turn off now but for everyone
else
i'm definition and welcome to the
channel where i ruin it so you don't
have to
set in 1984 we follow stefan a game
designer who is showcasing his game
banner snatch
based on the book of the same name we
watch him start the day by smiling
because he chose sugar puffs and then
the now too
which is of course the right thing to do
as this allows us to hear the eurythmics
and start the day off on the right track
upon reaching the game design studio we
see a poster for metalhead which of
course ties into the black mirror
episode of the same name
and confirms that this was indeed a
computer game as many viewers theorized
stefan then showcases his game
bandersnatch which too revolves around
choices
similar to the episode itself stefan
accepts a job offer from the company and
we flash forward five months and see
that banner snatch is receiving
extremely negative reviews stefander
finally states that he wishes to start
again and we are transported back to the
beginning
aware of the outcome now stefan refuses
to offer to work with the team and
instead states that he wishes to
complete the project from home alone we
then joined the character in therapy
discussing his mother's passing which i
decided to talk about openly
we learned that after stefan couldn't
find a child's toy that his father hid
he refused to go with his mother and she
was killed on a train that derailed
stefan feels guilt but also blames his
father for hiding the toy
this highlights that even the most
meaningless events have ground
consequences when out shopping stefan
picks up a book called
the lives of jerome f davies which
discusses the biography of the creator
of the band snatchbook
stefan uses the perspectives presented
in it and redesigns his game
here i chose shouting at his father
instead of destroying the game as this
seemingly was the lesser of two evils
but in the end it caused the character
to spiral further into his obsession
this was made worse when i made stefan
refuse therapy and instead had him
follow colin who makes him take
lsd in order to heighten his reality and
to help pull him out of the hole he is
in at design wise
colin informs stephane that time is
cyclical and that mirrors allow you to
move through time and through flashbacks
we can alter the choices we make to
alter the present
colin proves that life doesn't matter
because of the altered paths and commits
suicide which causes stephane to
flashback and choose to go to his
therapist instead of chasing colin
stefan was medicated but i chose to
flush these instead
to focus on the game when demoing banner
snatch though we discover that colin is
missing and that the game is broken
however there was a mysterious package
left behind by colin
this tape discusses the life of jerome
who likes stefan became obsessed about
branching paths of reality and became
completely swept up with murdering his
wife
stefan nearly destroys his computer but
refuses to which eventually leads to him
discovering a password encrypted
computer
i incorrectly entered the password which
caused the situation to reset and when
trying to destroy the computer once and
for all
i could not stefan realizes that forces
are controlling him and questions what
they are
the show then completely breaks the
fourth wall and states that we are on
netflix watching him
and we attempted to explain this but
failed to this caused stephane to fall
further into therapy as he attempted to
understand the scenario
stefan then ramps up the action when
tempted to and throws coffee in his
therapist's face
before fighting her and his father this
caused the timeline to reset and we hid
that we were netflix but it still caused
stefan to realize that he was not in
control which allowed us to make the
choice to kill his father
we then chopped up the body and had a
breakthrough with the game that allowed
stefan to finish it
by only giving the player the illusion
of free will the game then receives rave
reviews and we flash forward and
discover that stefan was arrested
shortly after its release
and that colin's daughter is now a games
designer that is developing a game for
netflix
based on banner snatch she soon
discovers stefan within the code trapped
and reliving the same choices
destroying the computer in order to stop
the events from playing out once more
but maybe it would have had a different
outcome had i made different choices
what i love about the show is that it's
a true representation of life
life is just a constant set of choices
that all wield different outcomes
that will alter the path we walk on it
significantly stefan's life could have
easily gone a completely different
direction but due to seemingly
insignificant choices there are
completely different outcomes
a bandus snatch is a fierce mythical
creature immune to bribery and capable
of moving very fast
and to me this holds many connotations
over the show throughout the episode
stefan is often bribed and tempted with
certain choices that he believes will
alter his life for the better even if
they have negative effects
in the end though he is completely
corrupted by the knowledge that there is
no real choice and that we are all on a
path to our ultimate end
it's a genius move that highlights that
individuality is an illusion and that we
are all more similar than we would care
to admit
i absolutely love the show and can't
wait to watch it again to see how
differently the story could have gone
to me the episode was absolutely
incredible and stands strong as the next
step of evolution in television
so what did you think of the black
mirror special did you enjoy it and what
ending did you get
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of bird box
which will be linked at the end
netflix blocked the video twice so i've
lost quite a lot of views on it and i've
had to start again each time
so i massively appreciate just one click
on it this is a channel for people who
are hardcore into horror so if that's
the kind of thing you like
hit subscribe thanks again for taking
the time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i hope you have a great 2019.
take care peace speaking of
great choices you should make the choice
to
just just click that subscribe button go
on just click it
just click it go on stephane would do it
[Music]
peace
you